bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 78 weekend
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs et
vos idées de sorties pour le weekend
vous le savez au programme des
expositions annepaté du théâtre de la
musique ou encore du sport mais tout de
suite place à notre invité tout de suite
avec elle nous parlons d'art et de
peinture
alors tous les deux mois dans le cadre
du projet artiste d'ici la médiiathèque
de saint-exupéri de voisin le Bretonneux
propose une exposition à découvrir et en
ce moment c'est Emmanuel mercian de
Miller qui est à l'honneur et ce
jusqu'au 28 février bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes artiste peintre alors
peut-être pour commencer vous pouvez
présenter un petit peu vos vos œuvres
que vous proposez en ce moment à voisin
de Bretonneux tout à fait alors je
propose une trentaine de de tableau euh
de la peinture à l'huile essentiellement
sur un thme d'art floral euh avec
quelques personnages également euh j'ai
des j'ai aussi beaucoup de de diptiques
euh qui sont donc une articulation entre
les la réalité que l'on voit et une
évocation plus plus honérique de de ce
que l'on peut percevoir ou des diptique
en fait c'est c'est deux panneaux c'est
ça qui se complètent l' l'autre he c'est
toujours de c'est ce qu'on voit un petit
peu sur les images oui tout à fait et
pourquoi justement cette volonté de
faire toujours des diptiques c'est ces
deux ces de ces deux comparaisons de de
deux arts différents en fait la peinture
figurative donc la peinture figurative
c'est ce que l'on
peut on peut comprendre ce que ce que
l'artiste a voulu peindre la peinture
figurative pour moi était très
intéressante mais au bout d'un moment
j'ai eu besoin de la prolonger dans une
forme abstraite tout en gardant
l'origine de cette de cette abstraction
et donc faire un dialogue entre ce qui
est ce qui est dit et reconnaissable par
tout le monde et quelque chose qui est
plus évoqué plus du thème du ressenti de
l'évocation intérieure d'accord donc en
fait vous mêlez un peu la réalité
visuelle et les perceptions c'est un
petit peu ça finalement tout à fait ça
tout à fait ça je reprends les les la
même palette les les mêmes couleurs mais
je vais reprendre par exemple des formes
je vais faire des répétions de forme de
rythme et de de telle sorte que le tout
soit articulé de façon harmonieuse
d'accord est-ce que vous êtes inspiré de
d'artistes ou de courants artistiques
particuli alors j'aime beaucoup les
artistes contemporains américains car
ils ont une palette très très vive très
gai enfin ce ceux que ceux qui m'inspire
euh qui sont profondément figuratifs
également c'est quelque chose qui est
plus difficile à voir en France et et
avec avec une fraîcheur de une fraîcheur
de thon qui me qui qui me plaît beaucoup
on le voit sur sur les images qui sont
en train d'être diffusées justement
c'est beaucoup de couleurs de fleurs
vous l'avez dit pourquoi cette volonté
de de de beaucoup de couleurs de de ce
de ces fleurs qui se répètent dans vos
tableaux c'est
alors j'aime énormément la le le on est
dans un monde un petit peu terne
aujourd'hui on peut le dire au regard
des événements de ces derniers jours et
et je pense que l'artiste a besoin
d'apporter quelque chose de
plus qui fait du bien aux gens et qui
euh et qui et qui élève un petit peu
l'énergie intérieure des des des
personnes là on parle de de vos vres on
va peut-être revenir un petit peu sur
votre parcours euh alors c'est à l'âge
de 27 ans lorsque vous travaillez dans
une société informatique donc qui n'a
rien à voir que vous décidez de vous
lancer que s'est-il passé alors il s'est
passé que donc je travaille à la Défense
dans les grandes tours et mon le sens de
mon travail je perdais un petit peu de
vue le sens de mon travail et je me
souviens très bien de de de ce jour
particulier où j'ai eu une une BD de
Peter swien dans les mains et je me suis
mis à recopier un dessin et alors là
j'ai eu une bombe atomique qui m'est
tombé dessus et je me suis dit mais
c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut que je
fasse et là j'ai donc entamé un un
processus de transition qui a été assez
long et pour me dégager du donc du du
monde classique et aller plus vers vers
une vie artistique avec l'acquisition
des compétences et cetera petite
anecdote quand même apparemment vous
avez posé au départ un congé de 4 mois
pour partir en Australie ça s'est
transformé en 4 ans voilà voilà c'est
vrai qu'en partant j'avais quand même
rendu mon appartement j'avais réglé tout
ce qu'il fallait et et de fil en
aiguille de de rencontrre en en
rencontre d'expérience de vie ça s'est
prolongé un petit peu plus longtemps que
ce que j'avais imaginé donc vous êtes
parti en Australie vous êtes parti
également en Nouvelle-Zélande en
Indonésie en Thaïlande en Inde un peu
partout qu'est-ce que ces voyages vous
ont vous ont appris finalement
euh alors une une ouvert ouverture sur
le monde une ouverture sur d'autres
formes de de d'autres
de d'autres formes de de pensé surtout
j'avais toujours quand même le le le fil
conducteur de mes voyages ça toujours
été la peinture donc j'ai rencontré des
artistes en Nouvelle-Zélande j'ai fait
des stages en Nouvelle-Zélande j'ai vécu
avec des artistes des des communautés
d'artistes en Indonésie j'étais
rencontré des artistes en Thaïlande
en Inde aussi ça a toujours été le fil
conducteur mais c'est vrai que pour
vivre pendant ces 4 ans il a fallu aussi
que je trouve des moyens de subsistance
c'est pour ça que ça a été un petit peu
long parce que parce qu'il fallait à la
fois que je je
puisse générer de quoi de quoi de quoi
voyager pour pouvoir peindre et alors
votre technique a évolué aussi durant
durant ces voyages et grâce à ces
voyages de peinture et de d'artiste ah
oui tout à fait parce que alors moi je
suis partie plus avec dans l'idée de
faire de l'aquarelle parce que c'est un
médium assez léger et pratique et et au
final je me suis quand même rendu compte
que voy voyager c'est ça prend beaucoup
de temps beaucoup d'énergie vous changez
de pays il faut réapprendre une langue
il faut réapprendre des usces et
coutumes qui vous sont totalement
inconnu et et au bout d'un moment je me
suis rendu compte que pour vraiment
apprendre apprendre à peindre de façon
sérieuse par Paris c'était quand même un
super endroit donc je suis rentrée à
Paris très bien et justement vous êtes
installé vous avez installé votre
atelier tout récemment dans la vallée de
Chevreuse tout à fait tout à fait
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous proposez
qu'est-ce que vous faites en tant
qu'artiste alors donc je peins je fais
des expositions je suis dans je suis
représentée par des galeries au Havre
chez dans la galerie Pascal Frémont
àeré dans la galerie François girudeau
mais j'enseigne aussi j'aime énormément
enseigner et donc en ce moment
j'enseigne au Cercle d'art de mPas pas
loin d'ici euh j'enseigne principalement
de l'huile mais je fais aussi du pastel
et je donne des des stages de pastel euh
par ailleurs pastel qui n'est pas
représenté dans cette exposition parce
que c'est assez difficile de mélanger
les deux médiums très bien alors
l'exposition artiste d'ici donc je le
répète c'est jusqu'au 28 février à la
médiathèque Antoine de saintexupéré à
voisin le Bretonneux et ce samedi 17
janvier euh la artiste de cette
exposition donc c'est vous vous serez
présente de 15h à 18h pour des
rencontres et des démonstrations c'est
bien cela vous serez présente ce tout à
fait tout à fait je serai présente et je
pourrais euh enfin j'apporterai de mon
matériel si les gens veulent que je
fasse une démonstration c'est avec très
grand plaisir parce que j'aime de dans
la peinture il y a deux choses il y a le
ressourcement qu'apporte la peinture
mais il y a le plaisir de la
transmission et le plaisir de parler de
son art et la rencontre avec le public
pour moi et et me nourrit énormément
ainsi que la la
transmission euh technique émotionnel de
de ce qu'est la peinture très bien
espérons qu'on ait donné envie aux gens
de de venir merci à vous d'être venus
sur notre plateau merci beaucoup on
continue cette édition quant à nous avec
d'autres expositions à ne pas raté ce
weekend le festival de BD d'angoulem
démarre le 29 janvier et en prémiss la
médiathèque Jean Rousselot de guyoncour
propose en ce moment une exposition
consacrée aux super-héros les images
sont signées
patri à la médiathèque jean-rousselo de
Guill encour les super-héros sont de
sortie pour une exposition présentée
jusqu'au 31 janvier mais d'abord c'est
quoi un super-héros un super-héros c'est
quelqu'un qui est doté de super pouvoirs
et qui n'existe pas dans la vie réelle
mais auquel on aimerait bien ressembler
quelqu'un qui est qui a de la bravoure
qui ose défendre les autres qui bon qui
apporte des services qui aime les autres
aussi du pain sur les planches
pourrait-on dire pour Batman Superman
Wonder Woman qui n à bien se tenir mais
les super-héros c'est aussi notion plus
vaste le Comix et le super-héros c'est
des domaines qui sont des fois moins
connus
moins moins mis en avant en France
peut-être dans la bande Cinée c'est la
bande ciné américaine surtout et puis le
héros le super-héros je crois que c'est
c'est des choses qui sont d'actualité et
on peut être un héros très connu et un
héros anonyme enfin la notion du héros
elle est elle est intéressante je trouve
au 20e siècle Enfin 21e même une notion
d'autant plus forte en cette période que
le héros actuel s'appelle Charlie des
affiches et des panneaux pour expliquer
le sens du super-héros des grandes
firmes américaines aux productions
françaises c'est donc à découvrir
jusqu'au 31 janvier à la médiathèque
jean- Rousselot en bonus une collection
de bandes dessinées et de figurines
proposé par un adhérent de la
médiathèque et nous restons dans
l'univers de la bande dessinée jusqu'au
31 janvier la médiathèque é césr de la
verrière propose une exposition autour
des mangas l'occasion de découvrir les
précurseurs les séries cultes et les
différentes approches entre les pays
asiatiques à Noé pour les passionnés la
médiathèque compte 2242 ouvrages de
mangas très exactement et le weekend
prochain Bruno rouané animera un atelier
de création de bande dessiné de 15h à
17h exposition toujours cette fois-ci
créée par des élèves et pas n'importe
lesquels il s'agit en effet des élèves
les plus confirmés du conservatoire des
arts de montinil le Bretonneux il
présente actuellement leurs œuvres
Louise elbois et Elodie moine se sont
rendus sur
place ils sont amateurs mais eux aussi
ont le droit à leur exposition depuis 8
ans le conservatoire des arts de Montini
le brotonux leur donne les moyens de
montrer ce qu'ils savent faire grâce à
l'exposition peinture volume c'est le
travail des élèves depuis le mois de
septembre donc bon certains ont
travaillé effectivement déjà au moins 3
mois sur l'étoile ou sur leur sculpture
et puis d'autres ont encore même du
travail à poursuivre encore encore un
petit peu cette exposition c'est aussi
un moyen de désengorger celle de fin
d'année surchargé par l'imagination des
artistes le conservatoire des arts
compte près de 700 élèves leurs œuvres
montrent les aspects techniques et la
progression réelle des élèves depuis
maintenant 14 ans cette année ils ont
choisi tableau trompeleœil ou encore
sculpture l'ensemble que vous allez là
la série des portraits ils sont partis
effectivement d'une photo ils nous ont
travaillé uniquement avec des comédiens
de la Comédie française alors il y a
vrai vraiment cette volonté de
travailler sur l'aspect très scénique
également c'est pour ça que en regardant
les portraits ils sont placés de façon
un petit peu particulière dans l'espace
il y avait cette volonté là de
travailler sur sur le portrait avec cet
aspect également fini non fini certains
ont encore voir un petit peu des traits
au fusin d'autres n'ont pas de coup donc
donne une image un petit peu flottante
et puis un peu étonnante sur la toile
l'exposition est à voir et à revoir au
Conservatoire jusqu'au 20
janvier allez quelques dates pour les
amateurs de théâtre à présent et
direction tout de suite guon cour pour
un match d'improvisation théâtrale ce
samedi 17 janvier à 20h30 l'équipe
junior de l'association app pas de géant
appelé les improchables rencontre les
gadgets de Reuil mal maison et l'en jeu
et de taille car il s'agit d'une épreuve
du championnat des ivelines compté 3 €
pour l'entrée à voisin le Bretonneux la
compagnie gardefou propose une création
inspirée d'une œuvre d'Umberto eo
comment ne pas parler de foot comment
éviter les maladies contagieuses une
chercheuse auocnrs et son assistante
vont faire la lumière sur tous ces
comment qui envahissent l'existence
elles seront sur scène ce samedi 17
janvier à 21h à la salle de la tour
voici un
extrait comment manger en AB parmi les
nourritures salissantes on a les
spaghettis bolognaises le goulache le
gratiné à peine sorti du four ou le
consommeré bouillant servi dans une
tasse sans
mais si on fume de la main droite
secouer la cendre à la gauche de son
épaule gauche nécessite un ensemble
d'opérations complexes entre autres
détourner le regard de la route et si la
voiture roule à 180 km
se servir du cendrier en ayant une
seconde distraction et qui doit
commettre le péché de sodomie avec un
camion les auteurs de ces notices
menteuses ont appris depuis leur plus
tendre enfance que lorsque l'on doit
dire quelque chose il faut dire tout ce
que l'on sait et rien que ce que l'on
sait ni plus ni moins donc c'est
pourquoi la rubrique contre indication
on lit souvent allergie à l'un des
composants du produit alors en d'autres
termes cela veut dire que si vous prenez
ce médicament et qu'aussitôt après vous
vous écroulez à terre avec de la bave
verte à la bouche et et un LAN phogramme
plat cela signifie que vous devez
interrompre le traitement et tout de
suite la page musique de cette édition
elle est harpiste elle s'appelle
Isabelle Olivier et sera à la ferme de
bbas ce samedi 17 janvier à 18h Nicolas
Gervet l'a
rencontré fameuse arpiste ouverte aux
sonorité jazz elle présente un projet
d'opéra avec des musiciens français et
américains un projet adapté du baron
percher d'Italo Calvino pour nous parler
de cet hymne à la liberté qui sera
présenté le 17 janvier à la ferme de BBA
avant une forme plus légère en mars à la
Maison de la Poésie voici Isabelle
Olivier dans le
[Musique]
kiosque
c'est un livre d'Italo Calvino qui
s'appelle le Baron Perché je l'ai lu
quand j'avais 11 12 ans et c'est vrai
que c'est un livre qui m'a accompagné à
différentes étapes de ma vie et qu'à
chaque étape de ma vie finalement je
voyais le même livre mais décliné avec
des on va dire des reliefs différents et
qui m'a toujours amené à des réflexions
profondes quelque chose de très
philosophique qui est le droit à la
différence qui est qu'est-ce que c'est
que d'être
libre qu'est-ce que c'est que on va dire
vivre en harmonie avec la nature
qu'est-ce que c'est que être en harmonie
avec les hommes et ce jeune garçon de 11
12 ans qui dit non à un plat d'escargot
va avoir cette envie de vivre dans un
arbre et de plus jamais revenir sur
Terre à travers cette fable
finalement se déroule une partie de
l'humanité qui est totalement
[Musique]
contemporaine mon album précédent était
une déclinaison de chansons quand je
suis arrivée à la fin de ces chansons
j'avais envie de partir sur une histoire
construite et la notion d'opéra jazz m'a
vraiment piqué de curiosité et de
passion et d'envie et effectivement ce
cette histoire là se prête extrêmement
bien au jazz parce que ce jeune homme
qui part vivre seul dans son arbre
quelque part improvise sa vie mais en
même temps en ayant cette capacité de
d'innover et que quelque part pour moi
le jazz c'est un peu ça c'est cet esprit
libre et d'innover à partir d'une
tradition musicale qui est à la fois la
tradition européenne de debusi de Ravel
de tous ces grands maîtres et aussi de
ce qu'a apporté les États-Unis sur le
[Musique]
rythme on continue en musique avec cet
opéra qui vous est proposé ce weekend
l'élyir d'amoret sous la direction de
David Stern sera joué ce samedi 17
janvier à 20h30 au Théâtre de de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline pensez à
réserver sur le site de kiosk il y en a
pour tous les goûts pas de jaloux les
amateurs de jazz sont servis aussi cette
fois-ci ça se passe au prisme d'élancour
samedi à 21h Cécile mclorine Salvant
virtuose de l'univers du jazz vocal il
sera en représentation je vous propose
un
[Musique]
extrait
et enfin les amateurs y trouvent aussi
leur compte ce weekend car un karaoké
vous est proposé attrape de passionnés
s'arrête à la médiathèque Anatole France
ce samedi rendez-vous dès
15h allez on passe au sport avec du
badminton le Palais des Sports
d'élencour accueille un tournoi national
ouvert aux joueurs classés et non
classés en double et double mixte
l'entrée libre et ouverte à tous place
maintenant à l'actualité
cinéma et tout de suite les sorties de
la semaine et les avis des spectateurs
au micro d'elody Mo j'adorais c'est un
film qui traite bah des souvenirs d'une
enfant qui est abandonné qui recherche
son passé mais moi j'adore bon je suis
une fan de manga donc tout ce qui
m'engage dès que ça sort je vais voir
j'étais un peu déçu quand même il y avit
beaucoup de de d'aller-retour de
flashback peut-être trop et on finit par
s'y perdre un peu dans le film il était
très bien très bien tourné très bien
monté etmouvant
vraiment bien c'est un film très mouvant
on passe du rire au larme rapidement et
non on sort pas ind différent surtout
sur le comment le sujet des des
grands-parents qu'est-ce qu'on en fait à
partir d'un certain Geo je super bien
ils sont tous vraiment très crédibles
c'est un film qui qui est génial plein
d'amour touchant j'aime beaucoup Michel
Blanc là il a un foutu caractère c'est
très drôle et an Cordi est
touchante voilà les jeunes les vieux la
vie c'est superbe un humour mais
extraordinaire j'oserais dire à la
harakéie à la charlesbdo un film
argentin à hurler de rire sur des sur
une
dénonciation sociale et notre coup de
cœur de la semaine c'est celui de Luc
beaucan du ciné 7 d'lancour alors
bonjour donc mon coup de cœur le coup de
cœur du ciné cette semaine c'est un film
noir parce que nous aimons les films
noirs au ciné 7 un polar même l'affaire
SK1 donc ça raconte en fait la traque du
premier sérial killer français c'est un
film de Frédéric Tellier qui est très
réussi qui est très intense très nerveux
avec un beau casting puisque à laaffiche
on a Nathalie baay Olivier Gourmet
Raphaël personaz voilà donc je vous
encourage après la french de Cédric
Giménez de nouveau un poar
français
numéroier
et puis aussi un deuxième petit coup de
cœur pour une soirée qu'on organise avec
une association qui s'appelle la brise
du mamouth qui est qui a été monté par
de jeuneslan courtois et morpasien et on
fait une soirée zombie donc vendredi à
partir de 21h et on projettera de film
zombie 2 et de la morte et de la mort
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité dès lundi
sur TV fil d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend